inside the Queens on the throne
I'm Alan Peter from Dawson machine
you're famous in Germany John Tick Tock
has 7.6 million views it's like a
million views move to Berlin and work
with me I can make you a star I'm moving
to Germany baby
I wonder who star is here nice to meet
you bumper Eddie it's amazing should be
your assistant too
yep
[Music]
you are going to perform at German uni
today it's like the Fourth of July meets
a Super Bowl halftime show except that
we are way cooler about showing nipples
here
Trump Emmons I'm going to try to play at
Unity deck it doesn't have some rage I
can go from two to
think that
yeah you know so I'm amazing
the proper performance is hard even for
the most seasoned performers don't worry
I work better under pressure what's up
nope nope
I've wanted to be famous my entire life
I thought Berlin was gonna change
everything
[Music]
if you don't take a risk you don't cry
[Music]
song is a bang what if we turn this into
a riff
offense you are obsessed with your whip
off riff-off Riff Off Riff Off you said
with of acid without okay
[Music]
thank God
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm not like a corny acapella guy I'm
cool right
right